[Музика]
Ласкаво просимо назад, і ми продовжуємо говорити
про роботу, хлопці, сьогодні ми будемо розвивати
ваші мовленнєві навички, але перед цим
давайте виконаємо деякі вправи, тому що ви
повинні підготуватися, щоб мати можливість
вільно і красиво
говорити, перше завдання  подивіться, ви повинні
доповнити фрази словами
з поля і вирішите, які три фактори
будуть для вас найважливішими при
виборі роботи, і ви повинні навести
причини, перше слово - переваги
переваги означає щось хороше, як
бонуси, потім приходить  flexible ви чули
це слово кілька разів, перш ніж
flexible be flexible ви можете буквально бути
гнучким і бути гімнасткою або ви можете бути
гнучким і пристосовуватися або адаптуватися до нових
обставин,
потім з'являється слово робота, ви можете використовувати його
двічі, потім приходить материнство Материнство - це
щось про мами  або батько
це означає бути батьками, тож, можливо, ви побачите,
тоді платіть дуже приємне слово, яке нам
усім подобається, коли нам платять за наші роботи,
тоді просування по службі означає, що  т ви
йдете вище у своїй кар'єрі і
неприємне слово зараз, що впливає на ваш
вибір кар'єри, перші перспективи
О,
яке слово він би використав, а це
перспективи підвищення, коли я дивлюся на
нові професії я дивлюся на перспективи
підвищення я  амбіційна людина я
не хочу бути на одній посаді
все життя я хочу розвиватися в своїй кар'єрі
хочу стати начальником, можливо, одного разу
це означає, що я шукаю
перспективи просування по службі добре безпека
яка  чи потрібна мені безпека на роботі, і
це безпека роботи, це означає, що навіть якщо
станеться щось погане, я не втрачу
роботу або це означає, що моя компанія піклується
про мене, добре, це може бути гарною ідеєю,
коли ви обираєте кар'єру, якщо ви  компанія
піклується про вас, якщо у вас є
охорона роботи, це хороший варіант
подумати про цю кар'єру, добре, наступна.
Привіт, яка оплата лікарняних, коли
ми захворіємо, ми повинні залишатися вдома
цього правила ми не виконуємо  працюємо і, можливо, ми
не отримуємо грошей, але багато компаній
платять за хворобу  платіть за тих людей, які повинні
залишатися вдома, коли вони хворі, і
насправді це гарна ідея, і насправді
це ваша безпека роботи, ви відчуваєте себе в безпеці,
потім настає робочий час гнучкий час
ось підказка, щоб ваш робочий час
міг бути гнучким, це означає, що ви  вирішуйте,
коли ви повинні почати працювати або коли
ви можете піти, тому гнучкий графік роботи
також може бути дуже приємним, коли ви
вибираєте свою кар'єру, а потім настає пільга
або пільги, це справді приємна річ, додаткові
переваги пільг кожного місяця, коли ви
отримуєте свою зарплату  але раз на рік або раз
на півроку ви можете отримати
пільги чи бонуси в грошовому вираженні, або
ваша компанія може надати вам, наприклад,
автомобіль чи магічну страховку чи безкоштовну
освіту для ваших дітей, це все
пільги, які їм не дають  вам як гроші,
але вони надаються вам наші послуги
або щось, що полегшить і полегшить ваше життя,
дуже приємно
подумати, коли ви обираєте свою
кар'єру, якщо компанія дає вам перевагу
переваги пільг вони дійсно піклуються про
вас наступне задоволення
яке задоволення і, звичайно, це
задоволення, коли ви задоволені, коли
ви любите свою роботу, тоді ви не відчуваєте,
що ви свого роду раб, ви хочете
працювати  ви робите те, що вам подобається, і ви
відчуваєте себе щасливим, тому якщо ви
задоволені своєю роботою, це дуже
хороша кар’єра,
тоді настає відпустка, гей, відпустка означає, що
коли ви не працюєте, коли ви не на
службі, але все одно отримуєте гроші, ви заробляєте
ці гроші  протягом усієї роботи
тут і компанія платить вам цю
відпустку, щоб ви добре відпочили,
розслабилися і знову приготувалися до роботи,
а наступне материнство або
батьківство живете в багатьох
країнах світу, а не тільки перебування матері
з  діти, коли діти залишаються немовлятами
після народження дітей, але, звісно,
ьки також можуть залишатися зі своїми навичками, на
риклад, у Швеції об
два батьки повинні розділити цю відпустку та
роводити однакову кількість часу зі св
їми дітьми n  не тільки матері залишаються вдома
з новонародженими дітьми, але й батьки
, це дуже гарна ідея, вона допомагає
людям зберегти свою кар’єру та продовжувати
працювати, а не просто залишатися
вдома протягом тривалого часу.
кар'єрне життя, і давайте розставимо наступні
речення про кар'єру Marks у
правильному порядку. Я дам вам кілька
хвилин, щоб поглянути на ці
речення, а потім вам доведеться
розташувати їх так, щоб вони стали однією історією
життя Marks, до того ж я хочу, щоб ви
записали  слова та фрази, які ви побачите
жирним шрифтом, як великим шрифтом, а потім
я б хотів, щоб ви поповнювали свій
словниковий запас Quizlet з ними добре, хлопці, я зробив це
для вас, щоб переглянути його, а потім ми почнемо
виконувати завдання добре,
добре,
так  Сподіваюся, що ви зрозуміли всю
ідею, і ви прогортали весь
текст, тому перше речення – після
закінчення університету Марк вирішив
подати заявку на роботу молодшого інженера,
що є першим кроком у його кар’єрі,
і я б  як ви записати
фразу подати заявку на роботу означає попросити
роботу та написати своє резюме та супровідний лист,
друге речення – після
успішного співбесіди в Kimmel Tech PLC,
його найняли на посаду
, будь ласка, запишіть фразу
найнятий або прийняти на роботу що сталося
з Марком, а наступним є те, що Марк
старанно працював кілька років і
врешті отримав підвищення до
посади старшого інженера, запишіть фразу,
щоб отримати підвищення,
добре, наступне те, що з ним сталося,
хаотично зіштовхнулося з фінансами  труднощі
під час економічної кризи, і Марка
звільнили, і він був звільнений,
вони змусили його піти, і тому запишіть
тут фразу, яку слід звільнити,
через його великий досвід, він швидко
був прийнятий на роботу в іншу компанію на посаду головного
інженера, тому він отримав  найнявся запишіть
фразу, щоб отримати найму, потім що
з ним сталося наступного разу, Марк відчув, що потребує змін
у своєму житті, тому вирішив
повідомити про це та почати нову
кар'єру  позначка номер чотири була звільнена,
це означає, що його звільнили, він був
звільнений, він не хотів йти, але
компанія була змушена це зробити через
економічну кризу, але в реченні номер
шість ви бачите іншу фразу
і будь ласка  записати це означає
вручити його повідомлення, щоб ви записати
вручити чиєсь повідомлення або моє повідомлення, і
це означає, що ви прийшли до свого начальника
і ви хочете залишити роботу, тому він
хотів змін у своєму житті, і він прийшов
до  його бос і він розпочали нову кар'єру,
тож яку кар'єру він вирішив
стати самозайнятим і почати власний
бізнес як консультант,
запишіть фразу, щоб стати
самозайнятим і почати власний
бізнес як консультант добре тоді
останній фактично після 20 років
ведення власного бізнесу вирішив
достроково піти на пенсію, так що керуйте своїм бізнесом, у нього
була власна компанія, і він вирішив піти на
пенсію, можливо, він отримав достатньо грошей для
виходу на пенсію добре, хлопці, тому ви можете бачити це
слово жирним шрифтом  ва  найнятий подати заявку на роботу
був звільнений гарний найм він став
самозайнятим розпочати власний бізнес і
так далі вам знадобляться ці фрази, коли
ви будете говорити про свою
майбутню кар'єру добре, тепер ви готові
бути готовим до своєї промови  Я хочу
дати вам п’ять кроків, які допоможуть вам
зробити гарну презентацію, і
насправді їх дуже просто запам’ятати, вони
є основними кроками, які ви бачите.
аудиторія бачить ідеї слайдів I, а ми
моделюємо, і це створює основу слова,
давайте охопимо кожну літеру та підготуємося
до вашої презентації усна презентація,
тому перша буква B для мозкового штурму
добре, коли вам потрібно виступити, коли
вам потрібно зробити презентацію, у вас є
щоб об’єднати всі ваші ідеї в одну точку, я
зазвичай використовую ментальні карти, а ви можете зробити
такі карти на папері, або ви можете використовувати
спеціальні програми, яких в Інтернеті є лише кількість,
і вони
дуже зручні  ви можете редагувати їх, ви можете
дозволити іншим людям приходити, приєднуватися та
редагувати ваш мозок, ви редагуєте свою карту розуму,
і насправді ці ментальні карти дійсно
корисні, тому тепер ви розміщуєте основну тему
у великому колі в центрі
вашої сторінки, а потім ви  зробіть інші
лінії, і ви об’єднаєте їх навколо, і
ви пишете всі свої ідеї по
всьому одному великому колу, щоб і з’єднати
всю інформацію, ви можете помістити кілька
стрілок і ліній, щоб об’єднати всі ідеї,
а потім вони вказують на зв’язок
між  інформація, яку ви маєте, добре, це
було перше слово, мозковий штурм, отримайте
все, що ви знаєте по темі, і
подумайте, що другий – це аудиторія, коли
ви готуєтеся до своєї
презентації,
ви повинні пам’ятати, до кого
ви звертаєтеся до своєї сучасної
аудиторії  можуть бути вашими однолітками, вашими
однокласниками
та вашими вчителями, якщо ви здаєте тести,
або викладачами, тому ви повинні враховувати,
до кого ви звертаєтеся, якщо
ви звертаєтесь до своїх однолітків, до
однокурсників  Це повністю відрізняється
від викладачів і екзаменаційних завдань,
і дуже важливо, що ви
повинні зберігати лише ту інформацію,
яка важлива для вашої аудиторії, якщо ви
розповідаєте щось, що не важливо для
вашої аудиторії, вони втрачають увагу, і
вони  не слухати вас, тому якщо ви додасте
непотрібну інформацію, ви в кінцевому підсумку
втратите увагу аудиторії, а ваше
важливе повідомлення загубиться,
тому виберіть і ретельно подумайте, що
включити у свою презентацію.
по-різному когось для
когось краще послухати, для
когось краще побачити, для когось
краще доторкнутися, і ми всі
різні, і це насправді нормально, тому,
можливо, серед вашої аудиторії будуть люди,
які краще візуалізують об'єкти,
і тому ви  потрібні слайди, щоб
вони слухали, і їм потрібна картинка, тому,
коли ви створюєте слайди, ви повинні
пам'ятати, що говорити y  вам не потрібно
писати все на своєму слайді, покладіть
основну інформацію та говорите більше, ніж
люди можуть читати, тоді як люди в основному вміють
читати, не читайте для них, робіть
презентацію з невеликим текстом, а розмовляйте
переважно, і насправді ви можете використовувати
різні типи  презентації, щоб зробити
їх більш вільними, щоб зробити їх більш
цікавими та інтерактивними
, корисні не тільки PowerPoints,
спробуйте інші, які ми маємо в
Інтернеті, наприклад Prezi, це дійсно
дуже цікаво, як усе рухається
в цій презентації, добре, наступна
– це ідеї добре  ви повинні описувати ідеї
своїми словами, і ви повинні
звучати природно, якщо ви вчите свою
презентацію напам'ять і просто як
стоїте на місці, говорите і просто говорите
все напам'ять, тоді
презентація - це не життя, це не
цікаво дивитися або слухати таке  у
презентації використовуйте власні ідеї, використовуйте
власні слова, використовуйте власні емоції та
намагайтеся пояснити дуже складні речі, наприклад, якщо
ви пояснюєте їх своєму другові
кажучи дуже просто, добре,
і остання ідея полягає в тому, щоб симулювати кожен раз,
коли вам потрібно зробити презентацію,
перш ніж прийти до аудиторії,
симулювати вдома, можливо, вам потрібно буде
записати свою презентацію та використовувати
відео, має бути відео, на якому ви проводите
презентацію  і тоді ви зможете
оцінити, що ви зробили правильно, а що
зробили неправильно, а потім зніміть себе
вдруге, і ви побачите, що це
буде багато даних або просто скористайтеся
дзеркалом і поговоріть з дзеркалом і побачите
свої жести  щоб побачити вашу поставу і бути
більш впевненим зараз, я б хотів, щоб ви
уявили студента, який намагається
прийняти рішення щодо свого кар'єрного шляху,
і ось кілька ідей і запитання, які
ви можете спочатку обговорити, у вас є трохи
часу, щоб подивитися  Виконуючи завдання, добре,
як я вже сказав, я помістив величезну
хмару посередині, і воно говорить, що люди
можуть враховувати, вибираючи
кар’єрний шлях, чи пам’ятаєте ви першу
вправу, як у нас, вони схожі на
безпеку роботи на лікарняному тощо  потім я  У
мене є кілька інших ідей, як
продовжити свій шлях, можливо, почати власний
бізнес, отримати університетську освіту,
працювати волонтером, щоб допомогти людям, які
страждають, навчатися ремеслу через
навчання та працювати за кордоном, щоб отримати
новий досвід, а у вас є  хвилину
подумайте, а потім я зроблю свою
презентацію якось на місці
, добре, хлопці, тому якби я був
учнем 10-го класу
і я сидів на контрольній і мені
дали таке завдання, я б почав
щось на кшталт  це добре, тому що мої
люди повинні враховувати,
вибираючи кар’єрний шлях, я студент, тому
перш за все мені потрібно подумати про прогалину
тут або про отримання університетської освіти, я
думаю, що я не готовий просто розпочати свій
університетський ступінь  відразу після
школи, і я думаю, що перед тим, як отримати
університетську освіту, я б зупинився
тут і попрацював як волонтер, щоб допомагати
людям, які страждають, можливо, я поїду
за кордон і працюватиму за кордоном, щоб отримати новий
досвід і зміцнити свою англійську
Я  Я не впевнений, чи хочу я отримати
науковий ступінь, тому я спробую
вивчити ремесло через
навчання, думаю, що спробую
себе на якійсь жорсткій роботі чи
щось подібне, я спробую бути
студент, учень хорошого майстра і
вивчити ремесло, можливо, і я думаю, що
після свого відриву тут і моєї волонтерської роботи
та стажування я буду
готовий здобувати університетську освіту,
думаю, що ще деякий час я буду продовжувати
працювати  для компанії після отримання
університетської освіти, а потім я думаю, що
подумаю про відкриття власного бізнесу,
тому що у мене є деякі ідеї, і я
хочу працювати на себе. Я хочу бути, щоб мати
гнучкий графік, я хочу бути більш вільним
у виборі  добре, це моя відповідь,
можливо, ваші відповіді будуть ще кращими,
і я впевнений, що вони будуть
ще краще, тому скористайтеся цією картою розуму і
поговоріть хвилину-дві, використовуючи всі
фрази, які ви побачите на екрані make
на екрані друку або сфотографуйте, а
потім потренуйтеся вдома  Добре, хлопці, давайте
продовжимо зараз, ось інші екзаменаційні
завдання, які ви можете побачити під час здачі тестів з
англійської мови, і там написано: опишіть
успішний малий бізнес, який ви знаєте
і яким захоплюєтеся, ви повинні сказати, що таке
бізнес, хто керує бізнесом,
чим захоплюєтесь ви  і поясніть,
чому ви вважаєте, що це вдало, ці
точки називають рубрикою, і
вони є обов’язковими, про них потрібно говорити,
ви не можете відповідати тим аспектам, які ви
повинні охопити їх,
і я маю зразок відповіді, давайте прочитаємо
це, а ви  я побачу, як
відповів інший студент, добре, давайте прочитаємо. Я
пам’ятаю, що два роки тому у нас був лише один
бізнес у нашому місті, він швидко став
одним із улюблених місць для зустрічі молоді
, тепер вони
розширили франшизи майже в кожному
куточку  моє місто слава про кав'ярню
поширилася з вуст в уста і в моєму випадку
мені про це розповів друг, власник
мережі - молода жінка, якій лише 31
рік і на даний момент
я вже працюю  зацікавлена у відкритті вл
сного маленького кафе чи ресторану. Я ду
е захоплююся її роботою, во
а успішно створила нову на
ву справжньої їжі в от
ченні сучасного енергійного та міського кафе, що зн
йомить з іноземним стилем життя наше сі
ьське місто щоразу, коли я  ві
цей ресторан, він завжди був переповнений,
і це стосується всіх інших
кафе в нашому місті, а не лише одного
конкретного місця, нещодавно група
оголосила, що зібрала п’ять і
п’ять мільйонів доларів інвестицій
із закордонних фондів, це доводить, що
мережа кафе є  Вважається, що має великий
потенціал у подальшому розвитку та
стати ще більш успішним у
майбутньому. Ну, це зразкова відповідь,
людина охопила всю рубрику та
відповіла на всі запитання, і я хотів би
, щоб ви записали фрази, які ви бачите,
жирним шрифтом і, можливо  щоб переглянути цю
відповідь ще раз
зараз, як я оголосив це перед тим, як я зробив
таку самооцінку, жадібність до світових
презентацій, ну ви можете нам  e Цю сітку,
щоб оцінити себе, перш ніж
представити цю презентацію своїй аудиторії, у
першій таблиці ви можете побачити мовні
проблеми, а ви говорите
англійською, ви розмовляєте англійською, і у
вас можуть бути якісь помилки, і
якщо ви  Звичайно, складаючи іспити,
ви будете оцінюватися відповідно до ваших
знань англійської, а не лише щодо
ідей, які ви висловлюєте, тому спочатку ви
повинні визначити помилки, які ви робите, можливо,
ви використовуєте дуже поганий словниковий запас, або ви
неправильно вживаєте слова, або у вас є
проблеми з граматикою, і ви
повинні переглянути часи або ви повинні переглянути
інші граматичні структури, інший дуже
важливий аспект - це ваша вимова,
ви повинні зробити все можливе і
правильно вимовляти слова я не говорю
про акцент, очевидно, що ми
ми всі матимемо наголос добре, звісно,
пробуємо позбутися від нього з часом, ал
все одно добре мати акцент, ал
ви повинні правильно вимовляти слово, це
значає покласти цю довіру на
він правильне місце і так далі, тоді
другий аспект, який ви повинні оцінити, -
це комунікативні показники, і там у
вас є голосовий потік мови, контакт очей,
мова тіла і добре запам'ятовування, якщо
ви говорите занадто повільно або якщо ви
говорите занадто  тихо або якщо
ви говорите занадто голосно і висловлюєтеся
ось так, це
недобре  природний і не використовуйте занадто багато
мови тіла, нікому не потрібно, щоб використовувати
пристойну кількість вашої мови тіла
добре, у вас є ця сітка, яка допоможе
вам, якщо все гаразд або вам потрібно покращити
добре хлопці, тепер ви готові до своєї
домашньої роботи, тому  домашнє завдання - ти
збираєшся розповісти про свої кар'єрні
плани, ти будеш говорити не більше
двох хвилин, це не так багато, не забудь
сказати ось рубрика
обов'язково,
якою роботою ти хочеш займатися в майбутньому
пам'ятаєш  що кілька  уроки до
того, як ви повинні були робити нотатки про свою майбутню
кар’єру, то які предмети, на вашу
думку, є найважливішими для вашої
майбутньої роботи і чому доступ у цьому уроці є одним із них.
родичі, але насправді
майте на увазі, що саме ви
вирішуєте свою кар'єру, і вам доведеться
постійно лідирувати, а це означає, що вам не
потрібно зупинятися, ви можете використовувати
презентацію, якщо вам потрібно, якщо вам
дозволено використовувати її у своїх школах
Я сподіваюся, що ви отримали
всю необхідну інформацію, щоб
підготуватися до виконання домашніх завдань, і я
сподіваюся, що цей урок був дійсно корисним
для вас, любите англійську, залишайтеся з нашими новинами та
мийте руки
до побачення
[Музика]